[Music]
sleep is the elixir of
life but we are a chronically sleep
deprived society
and studies have shown us that one in
three people
don't get enough sleep as a
neuroscientist
at uc berkeley i am passionate about
sleep
so i have a mission i
desperately want to reunite humanity
with mother nature's best effort yet
at immortality
we often think of sleep as the third
pillar of good health alongside diet and
exercise
but in truth sleep is actually the
foundation
on which those two other pillars will
sit
i'm going to share with you the science
behind
what will enhance your sleep why it's
important
and how proper sleep can benefit your
life
in the brain during deep sleep hundreds
of
thousands of brain cells in your cortex
fire together
and then they all go silent together in
fact some parts of your
brain are up to 30 percent more active
when you go into rem sleep
than when you are awake
your brain and your body need to drop
their core temperature in order for you
to fall asleep
and then stay asleep soundly across the
night
so set your bedroom temperature to
about 68 degrees fahrenheit
and using sleep trackers it gives us a
historical record
of our sleep and they may become the
ultimate
secret sleep weapon
i believe it is time to reclaim
our right to a full night of sleep and
the opportunity
for a better life it is never too late
to start sleeping better i'm matthew
walker
and this is my master class
[Music]
you